l'info numéro 1 c'est auurg de Perpignan
des dizaines de patients sur des
brancards font la queue dehors faute de
place regardez ces vidéos qui ont fait
énormément parler
[Musique]
regardez
voil est
là plus en
encore Cardy est avec nous c'est
toujours un bonheur de vous avoir éic
porte-parole de la Fédération nationale
des sapeurs pompiers de France Éric
quand on voit ça on se dit c'est c'est
c'est c'est incroyable malheureusement
c'est ce qui peut se passer au quotidien
dans toutes les hôpitaux de France à un
moment donné lorsqu'il y a une trop
forte demande une trop forte pression
opérationnelle liée à une demande de
secours donc très clairement ces images
là elles montrent parfois la réalité il
faut le dire euh les sapeurs pompiers
c'est près de 4,5 millions
d'intervention c'est 4 millions liés au
secours d'urgence personnes c'est ce
qu'on voit là et c'est près de 3
millions de personnes prises en charge
donc très clairement on est sur un souci
aujourd'hui de pression opérationnelle
qui manque on va dire de d'être évacué
par le biais du sas des urgences c'est
pas forcément la meilleure des méthodes
que d'acheminer tout le monde vers les
urgences mais ça fait partie aujourd'hui
malheureusement d'un process sur lequel
on a du mal à revenir ou à interférer
parce qu'aujourd'hui ben tout est
imriqué entre les sapeurs pompiers le
Samu avec qui on travaille et ça repose
avant tout et qu'on tiens à dire sur des
humains et quand vous avez voilà les
saport pompiers comme les ambulanciers
comme le personnel hospitalier intérieur
ils tiennent la main des gens dans ces
inexorables moment d'attente et c'est
très clairement aujourd'hui une
souffrance que l'on vit que l'on partage
avec les gens et donc à cela le congrès
national des saports pompés de France
qui ouvre aujourd'hui va accueillir et
c'est une première le ministre de la
Santé au côté de du ministre de
l'Intérieur donc parce qu'on a ces
problèmes là on a ces problèmes
d'évacuation au niveau et d'anticipation
en terme de d'acheminement des des
victimes aux urgences c'est un pompier
hein qui a filmé la scène qui en avait
marre d'attendre et qui voulait montrer
la galère des urgences dans ce pays
c'est ça qui est fou he c'est un premier
lui-même qui voulait montrer cel g c'est
extrêmement rare et d'ailleurs vos
collègues ont dit mais on diffuse ça
parce que on ne devrait pas être là
parce que ça nous empêche d'être
opérationnel sur des urgences fa qui se
passe là c'est que le temps d'attente
qui est ici ça a des répercussions sur
le temps opérationnel vous savez en
France c'est 250000 sapeurs pompiers qui
soient professionnel mais aussi pour 80
% des volontaires donc ça veut dire
qu'ils ont quitté leur domicile ils ont
quitté leur activité les professionnels
ont aussi une comment une activité forte
et soutenue dans le cadre du du domaine
urbain puisqu'ils sont principalement
localisés dans cette dans ces zones-là
donc il est clair que le temps qu'on
passe là-dessus c'est des interventions
que l'on ne fait plus à côté et donc
forcément c'est un effet domino
inexorable qui tombe qui tombe au fur et
à mesure et quelque part c'est pas on va
dire très engageant vis-à-vis de la
fonction publique parce que très
clairement derrière qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah les sapeurs
pompiers réfléchissent les sapeurs
pompiers ont du mal continuer à agir et
il y a une perte de motivation il y a
une perte de sens mais ça on le voit
aussi dans l'épuration très clair des
services hospitaliers donc je crois
qu'aujourd'hui le cœur du sujet c'est de
remettre l'humain sur le vent de la
scène comprendre que la fonction public
aujourd'hui repose sur des hommes c'est
très clair et derrière cela vous avez du
temps de l'impatience et aujourd'hui on
est de moins en moins patient et il y a
des agression qui s'enchaîne derrière
donc très clairement c'est
malheureusement ce que ce que l'on voit
c'est c'est le résultat d'aujourd'hui
c'est mis en lumière vous l'avez aussi
pendant l'été vous avez eu pendant cet
été au mois d'août des urgences qui ont
fermé en plein mois d'oût à Saint-
Troupé par 163 services d'urgen sont
fermés au moins une fois cet été
exactement et c'est extrêmement
dangereux déjà d'une part pour la
distribution la prise en charge des
victimes mais très clairement aussi
derrière ça pose le souci du
rallongement du délai d'intervention et
donc forcément quoi faire il y a un
chiffre qui qui fait vraiment flipper
c'est en décembre 2022 écoutez bien chez
vous 19h58 ce ce chiffre il est fou 23
décès aurait pu être évité si les
patients avaient pu être pris en charge
rapidementroable alors c'est incro
incroyable et ça quelque part ça relève
aussi ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
réponse gradué c'est-à-dire qu'au sein
des territoires vous avez des sapurs
pompiers des secouriste plus plus comme
des ambulanciers comme des acteurs du
Samu mais au-delà de ça on doit avoir
une réponse graduée parce que ce que
vous avez vu à l'instant à l'écran ça
nécessite pas forcément un acheminement
aux urgences c'est-à-dire qu'entre
quatre brancards vous avez forcément une
personne qui est en détresse vitale et
ça ça ne peut pas attendre et donc
forcément force de constater qu'à
l'intérieur vous avez monsieur Madale
tout le monde qui ont décidé de
s'engager en tant qu'infirmier ou
infirmière et qui eux désespèrent aussi
pour essayer d'absorber ces mots de la
société de pouvoir y répondre mais
derrière on a une file d'attente qui qui
dure et clairement il faut trouver des
solutions qu'on va pouvoir établir avec
le ministre de la Santé lors du congrès
national des pompiers de France
actuellement il y a Christophe Climaco
secrétaire de l'union CGT santé des
Pyrénées orientales qui a dit même sans
une grande affluence on a souvent 6 he
d'attente aux urgences et 10h d'attente
ou 12 d'attente c'estes monnaie courante
ici on alerte depuis des mois et des
années pour avoir plus de moyens mais ça
ne vient pas oui non moi je trouve je
sais pas si je dis des conneries mais
j'ai un gros problème moi par exemple
j'ai plus de médecin traitant il est
parti à la retraite et j'avais un
problème avec mon enfant j'étais aux
urgences en fait j'avais rien à [__]
aux urgences si j'avais un médecin
traitant j'avais rien à [__] au urgen
peut-être que là des
gens mais dans les brancars ça se trouve
comme il dit il y a des gens qui on rien
à voir làdans exactement ça prenez la
même file d'attente en fait donc d'ù
l'idée peut-être de juste pour le
médecin traitant que tuas pas par voilà
donc il y a un gros problème avec le
leur idée de médecin traitant moi je
cherche un médecin là on par j'ai pas de
médecin en fait si demain je fais un
arrêt de travail au boulot j'ai pas de
médecin je pas les je lance un appel
s'il y a un médecin qui veut bien me
prendre moi et ma famille non mais c'est
on est là don mon père mais il aime pas
ta gueule non je rigole c'est ça qui est
en 2023 on est là en fait et je je dois
pas être tout seul mais qu'il y a pas
certains patients qui sont responsables
aussi parce que j'ai vu des reportages
où disaient que les urgences étaient
saturé à cause de gens qui se rendaient
aux urgences alors que c'était pas du
tout urgent du coup les cas urgents ne
passent pas non parce que oui toi tu
pouvais pas faire autrement les gens qui
décident deux même d'aller aux urgences
alors qu'il peuvent aller chez le
médecin
ur il y a des gens qui ont des médecins
et qui jugent que leur cas est urgent
qu' ne l' pas oui parfois ça s'appelle
la sistana je l'ai vécu parfois j'étaé
appelé j'ai attendu une personne j'ai vu
une personne aller vers vers cette
intervention là et la personne attendit
bore chez elle avec des valises donc
comment voulez-vous à un moment donné
comprendre le sens de votre mission et
comment expliquer à un moment donné que
c'est pas votre mission ce type
d'intervention donc très clairement on
est sur un sujet aussi de qualification
de l'urgence et on travaille sur le
terrain avec l'ensemble du Samu parce
que aujourd'hui il y a une régulation
qui se fait au téléphone mais qui ne
suffit pas qui ne suffit plus on a vu on
on va dire aujourd'hui un service
d'urgence au niveau du Samu qui était
mise à mal aussi et derrière ce sont des
hommes et des femmes au bout du
téléphone les sapurs pompiers c'est en
gros 12 minutes entre le moment où vous
décrochez l'appel des urgences et le
moment où vous avez des sapars pompiers
en bas de chez vous ce qui quand même
énorme en terme de service public mais
quelque part ça s frite et ça s' rode et
clairement derrière ça va être votre
enfant votre grand-père votre grand-mère
qui a forcément besoin et qui à ce
moment-là n'aura pas le recours
nécessaire au au niveau des
interventions au niveau du potentiel de
distribution des secours qui pour
intervenir parce qu'ils sont dans un fil
d'attente Jacques car quels étaient les
cas là ce jour-là parce que sont des
gens qui sont sur des brancards c'est
pas juste une file d'attente enfin a
l'impression que c'est des des cas
graves quand même alors déjà on peut pas
dire ce qu'il y a comme cas étant donné
que voilà c'est aussi un sujet de secret
évident mais le le le sujet derrière
c'est que vous avez de tout vous avez la
détresse morale vous avez la personne
qui se sent pas bien mais qui arrive pas
à déterminer ce qu'elle a vous avez les
moments de solitude je vous mets au défi
de comprendre ce qu' a votre voisin et
est-ce que vous serez au courant un jour
s'il va pas bien ou pas donc clairement
un mauvais aiguillage dès le départ une
mauvaise prise en charge aussi qui est
pas dû au niveau du service et parce que
quelque part comme j'arrive pas à
définir ce que j'ai ben je trouve la
solution la plus simple c'est de
solliciter les les urgences bien sûr oui
je sair est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui abusent c'est qu' au lieu
d'aller tout seul aux urgences font
appel à vous en disisant qu'il faont
être prioritaire en arrivant au service
des urgences oui ça arrive mais
malheureusement benah le cette vidéo
elle montre très bien une chose c'est
qu'on n'est pas prioritaire malgré qu'on
on soit dans pris en charge par les
urgences d'où le fait c'est de rappeler
nécessairement qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
parce qu'on appelle les sapeurs pompiers
que vous passerez plus vite devant tout
le monde tout à chacun a le droit
d'accès au niveau des urgences je pense
que comme on le disait entre le
ministère de l'Intérieur et le ministère
de la santé il y a un calibrage à
effectuer parce que nous sommes à la
fois sur sec cours d'urgence aux
personnes comme nous sommes aussi
rattaché à toutes les autres missions de
secours donc très clairement il y a des
voies d'accès de travail qui doivent
être dévoilé votre question n'était pas
ntait pas ouf euh non je crois pas si
si é bien était bien était bien pas Éric
brocardi ces images j'ai l'impression
qu'on les voit depuis des années sur nos
écrans c'est-à-dire que ces fils
d'attente ces brancards on les voit
depuis des années l'OMS nous dit qu'il y
a 15 millions de personnels soignant qui
seront qui dont on manquera d'ici 2030
c'est demain on fait quoi en fait on en
parle de non cyil sur JeanMichel jeis ah
bon pardon vous en fichez non mais on en
parle ça fait des années on est là on
monte les images rien bouge Ann il y a
eu des concentration euh on va dire de
reconcentration des des urgences dans le
domaine bah de l'accueil justement des
victimes euh derrière à savoir si cela
suffit clairement quand on voit les
images non très clairement il faut le il
faut il faut montrer à un moment donné
le sujet qui est fondamental c'est
comment on peut mieux traiter et ça a
été développé aujourd'hui avec des
solutions tout le monde peut-être entre
guillemets rigole de voir les
consultation via les téléphones via les
visos mais aujourd'hui ça peut être une
solution pour on va dire mettre un
tampon et ça peut faire baisser un petit
peu aujourd'hui il faut l'accepter sauf
que la fracture numérique est encore là
et que vous avez toujours des
malheureusement des personnes âgés
isolés sur lequel nous nous nous avons
le devoir d'être présent au k parce
qu'elles sont en détresse et très
clairement ça n'amortit pas le choc
ou ou une question Jean-Michel deè
question merci je vais qu'on appiss er
brocardi merci voir Paro à la
Fédération on va se retrouver dans un
instant inflation un français sur TR
c'est déjà primé de repas faute de
moyens tous les conseils de Norbert
Norbert t sera avec nous pour manger
bien et pas cher c'est important etorber
on est très content de le voir il arrive
dans une seconde à tout de suite
[Musique]